[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وفي الوقت الذي يحدثكم فيه
تتفاعلوا احداث وتقع اخرى البدايه من رام
الله مدينه تعيش على واقع التوتر وتصعيد
الفضه الغربيه تزاملا مع انعقاد مؤتمر
الشرم الشيخ الخماسي بحضور الفلسطيني
واسرائيلي
طهران وهنالك تصريح لمسؤول في الرئاسه
الايرانيه يقول فيه ان الرئيس الايراني
رحب بدعوه تلقاها من العاهل السعودي
لزياره الرياض
باريس ما زالت في جدل قانون التقاعد عشيه
اقتراع حاسم في الجمعيات الوطنيه لحجب
الثقه عن الحكومه حكومه
غضب شعبي بشان تعديل نظام التقاعدي في
فرنسا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
على وقع توتر وتصعيد في الضفه الغربيه
لقاء خماسي في شرم الشيخ بحضور فلسطيني
واسرائيلي وبعد اسابيع من الشمال العقبه
اتفاق على السعي لاتخاذ اجراءات لبناء
الثقه وتعهد الاسرائيلي بوقف مناقشه انشاء
اي وحدات استيطانيه لمده اربعه اشهر
بعد ايام من الاتفاق على استئناف علاقات
طهران والرياض ايران تقول ان الرئيس رئيسي
تلقى دعوه من العاهل السعودي لزياره
المملكه وتكشف عن اتفاق على اجتماع مقبل
على مستوى وزيره الخارجيه وتقترح ثلاثه
مواقع لعقد اللقاء دون تحديدها
في تصريحاته للجزيره رئيس الوزراء
العراقيه قور انه يامل ان يكون الاتفاق
الامني لحمايه الحدود مع ايران عامل
استقرار للاوضاع وان العلاقه بين ايران
وامريكا وبعض دول الخليج يجب الا تنعكس
على الداخل العراقي ويؤكد رفض الاعتداء من
اراضي العراق على اي دوله جاره
[موسيقى]
بعد مذكره توقيف بحقه من المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بوتين في مريول الاوكرانيه لاول
مره منذ سيطره الجيش الروسي عليها كيف
تنتقد الزياره وتقول انها تمت ليلا لاخفاء
مشاهد الدمار واشنطن تعتبرها دعايه هدفها
اظهار سيطره الرئيس الروسي على ساحه
المعركه
وفي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصات
الرقميه ناقشنا السياقه اجتماعات شرم
الشيخ الخماسيه بين السلطه الفلسطينيه
واسرائيل برعايه امريكيه مصريه اردنيه في
محاوله لتهدئه الاوضاع ووقف التصعيد في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه والاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما هي احتمالات وقف التصعيد
الاسرائيلي في الضفه الغربيه بعد اجتماع
شرم الشيخ
النتائج والتصويت جاءت على النحو التالي
17% رجحوا وجود احتمالات كبيره لوقف
التصعيد وصوت 23% لصالح خيار وجود
احتمالات محدوده بينما صوت 60% قائلين انه
لا توجد اي احتمالات اطلاقا لوقف التصعيد
في الضفه الغربيه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم الدخول الى صفحه التصويت
عبر مسح رمز الكيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا في المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا
وفي فقره المتابعه نرصد بعد قليل في ربع
عرض للقوه خلال اسبوع كوريا الشماليه تطلق
صاروخا بارستيا قصيره المدى اواشنطن تعلن
اعاده نشر قاذفه قنابل في شبه الجزيره
الكوريه
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم في اعقاب اجتماعي عقد في شرم
الشيخ المصريه بمشاركه وفد فلسطيني واخر
اسرائيلي برعايه امريكيه مصريه اردنيه قال
بيان ختمي ان المشاركين اكدوا التزامهم
بتعزيز الاستقرار والسلام للفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وبالسعي لاتخاذ اجراءات
لبناء وتعزيز الثقه وفتح افاق سياسيه كما
اكدت اسرائيل وسلطه الفلسطينيه استعدادهما
والتزامهما المشترك بالتحرك الفوري لانهاء
الاجراءات الاحاديه لفتره تمتد بين ثلاثه
الى سته اشهر ويتضمن ذلك التزاما
اسرائيليا بوقف مناقشه اي وحدات استيطانيه
جديده لمده اربعه اشهر ووقف اصدار تراخيص
لاي نقاط استيطانيه لمده سته اشهر
اتفق الجانبان ايضا على استحداث اليه
للتصدي للعنف والتحريض والتصريحات
والتحركات التي قد تتسبب في اشتعال الموقف
كما اتفقت الاطراف على الالتزام بعدم
المساس بالوضعيه التاريخيه للاماكن
المقدسه في القدس فعلا وقولا وفق البيان
وقدرت حركه حماس مشاركه سلطه الفلسطينيه
في اجتماع شرم الشيخ الامني اليوم بحضور
اسرائيل التي قالت حماس انها تصاعد
عدوانها ضد الشعب الفلسطيني وجدت الحركه
في بيان صدر اليوم دعوتها للسلطه
الفلسطينيه للتوقف الفوري عند الانزلاق في
مسار المشاريع الامنيه الخطيره التي
تستهدف مقاومه الشعب الفلسطيني واكدت
مجددا ان هذا المسار لا يخدم سوى الاحتلال
واطاله امده وتحسين صورته دوليا على حساب
الحقوق المشروعه للشعب الفلسطيني وضعت
حماس السلطه الى وقف كل اشكال التنسيق
الامني مع اسرائيل واجهزتها الامنيه بلا
رجعه كما جاء في البيان
ومن ناحيه الثانيه قال القيادي في حركه
الجهاد الاسلاميه خالد البطش ان قمه شرم
الشيخ هي محاوله امريكيه لفك العزله عن
حكومه نتنياهو موضحا ان مشاركه السلطه في
القمه تشكل طوق نجاه لحكومه اليمين
المتطرفه في تل ابيب
وفي غزه نظم المؤتمر الشعبي الفلسطيني
ومنظمته شبابيه وقفتها احتجاجيه في مدينه
غزه رفضا لاجتماع شرم الشيخ الامنيه الذي
يبحث التهدئه في الضفه الغربيه وعبر
المؤتمر الشعبي الفلسطيني في بيان عن رفضه
اجتماع شرم الشيخ الامني الذي يعقد مع
الاحتلال وتشارك فيه السلطه الفلسطينيه
دون اجماع وطني وندد البيان بما سماه نهج
السلطه الفلسطينيه الاستسلامي وطلب بتصعيد
اشكال الاحتجاج كافه ووصف المؤتمر الشعبي
الفلسطيني والمشاركه في الاجتماع بانها
استكمال للمؤامره على المقاومه وخيار
الشعب داعيا الى انهاء الانقسام الفلسطيني
والتوحدي خلف المقاومه وفق البيان
وتحت لافته التهدئه وخفض التصعيد اذا
التام الجمع في اجتماعي العقبه وشرم الشيخ
لكن الفتره بين الاجتماعين لم تشهد ما
يشبه التهدئه بل اكتسمت بالتصعيد فقد
استشهد حسب وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه خلالها
اربعه وعشرون فلسطينيا في عمليات التوغل
اسرائيلي واعتداءات من جانب المستوطنين
لم يكد حبر تفاهمات اجتماع العقبه الذي
عقد في السادس والعشرين من الشهر الماضي
جيف حتى بدات الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه وما
قال الفلسطينيون انه تنصل الاحتلال من
التزاماته حيث نفذت قوات الاحتلال 380
اقتحاما لمناطق الضفه الغربيه والقدس
المحتله منذ التئام العقبه وحتى السابع
عشر من هذا الشهر حسب احصائيات مركز
المعلومات الفلسطيني ابرز ما توافق عليه
في العقبه خفض التصعيد والحفاظ على الوضع
القائم في القدس لكن وزير الامن الداخلي
الاسرائيلي اتمر بن كبير اقتحم جبل صبيح
بعد ساعات من اجتماع العقبه رد المقاومه
على الاجتماع ومعقبه من اقتحام كان في
بلده حواره التي شهدت عمليه اطلاق نار
اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنين بعدها اعتدت
مجموعات من المستوطنين على ممتلكات
الفلسطينيين في البلده وقرى جنوبي نابلس
بالضفه الغربيه واحرق مستوطنون احد
المنازل في البلده تحت قوه الاحتلال اكثر
التصريحات التي لاقت انتقادات دوليه ما
جاء في الاول من مارس على لسان وزير
الماليه الاسرائيلي
الذي دعا الى محو بلده حواره من الارض وفي
اليوم نفسه صدق الكنيست بالقراءه
التمهيديه على مقترح يقضي باعدام الاسرى
الفلسطينيه المتهمين بعمليات اسفرت عن
مقتل اسرائيليين وفي السابع من مارس وبعد
مطارده استمرت اياما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
مدينه جنين وبمساعده قوات خاصه قتلت سته
فلسطينيين بينهم منفذ عمليه حواره بعدها
بيومين وفي التاسع من مارس اطلقت القوات
الاسرائيليه النار على سياره في جنين
واسفر الحادث عن استشهاد ثلاثه فلسطينيين
خلال اليوم نفسه لكن في قلب تل ابيب جاء
الرد الفلسطيني حيث اطلق شاب النار على
مجموعه من المستوطنين في شارع ديزنجوب
واصاب خمسه منهم قبل ان يتعطل مسدس عمليه
تبنتها حركه حماس في اليوم الموالي وقالت
ان ها رد طبيعي على جرائم الاحتلال
اليوميه
[موسيقى]
وفي غضون ذلك قال طور وانسلاند المبعوث
الامامي للسلام في الشرق الاوسط ان
القيرتين الاسرائيليه والفلسطينيه بحاجه
الى اتخاذ قرارات استراتيجيه من اجل ان
يمر شهر رمضان دون تصعيد واضاف وانسلاند
في تصريحات لموقع ولا الاسرائيلي ان من
الصعب للغايه لاتفاقها على استراتيجيه
لاحتواء التصعيد بسبب انعدام الثقه بين
الاسراليين والفلسطينيين واوضح المبعوث
الامامي ان تنفيذ تفاهمات اجتماع العقبه
يمكن ان تساعد في دفع الامور نحو الاتجاه
الصحيح وبشان تنصر الحكومه الاسرائيليه من
نتائج اجتماع العقبه قال ونسلاند انه لا
يمكن لاحد القول انه لا يوافق على ما وقع
عليه
وشدد وانسلاند على ان ضمانه الهدوء
والسلام في الضفه الغربيه وشرق القدس
مفتاح للحفاظ على الهدوء في غزه وقال ان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا تولي الاهتمام
الكافي لعنف المستوطنين لافتا الى انه لا
يمكن تكرار ما حدث في حواره
معنى من واشنطن دكتور دانيال استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جون هوبكنز
ومعنا من رام الله الدكتور غسان الخطيب
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت
وابدا بضيف دكتور غسان
بيان بيان اجتماع شرم الشيخ يرتب التزامات
على الجانب الفلسطيني كان يتوقف عن
اجراءات من جانب واحد يمنع التحريض واي
تحركات يمكن ان تشعل الموقف هل لذلك اي
تفسير اخر سوى استئناف التنسيق الامني
وبقوه
لا اعتقد ان هناك اي اهميه
لقرارات التي صدرت عن ذلك الاجتماع ولا
اعتقد ان ذلك الاجتماع له اي اهميه لسبب
بسيط وهو
ان المجتمعون في شرم الشيخ تماما مثل
الذين كانوا مجتمعين في العقبه
لا يستطيعون او لا يرغبون في التاثير على
مجريات الوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله الحكومه الاسرائيليه ما بين غير
راغبه وما بين غير قادره على وضع حد
لاستفزازات المستوطنين التي يؤدي
استمرارها الى ردود فعل مقاومه فلسطينيه
والطرف الفلسطيني الموجود في شرم الشيخ
ليس لديه قدره او امكانيه للتاثير على
ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه المقاومه ولذلك
جاءت قرارات شرم الشيخ بعبارات فضفاضه
عامه يعني للاستهلاك
الداخلي لدى الاطراف التي عملت على تنظيم
هذا الاجتماع لذلك لا اعتقد انه هناك
اهميه كبرى ولا اعتقد بانه سيكون له اي
تاثير على واقع حياتنا في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله هل هذا رايك ايضا
دكتور دانيال ان الاجتماع تحصيل حاصل وان
العبارات هي العبارات الفضفاضه ذاتها التي
عاده ما تستخدم في مثل هذه الاجتماعات ثم
تصطدم بالواقع الذي لا يعترف بذلك كله
ان يكون خطا كلامه لكنه حقيقه هو محق في
كلامه لان لا يوجد دليل على صحه تطبيق اي
شيء
والدليل هو دائما في التطبيق
والاسرائيليين على وجه
الدقه اخفقوا في تطبيق اي شيء اتفقوا عليه
في اللقاء العقبه ولا ارى اي نهايه لهذه
الامور الان انت ترى ذلك وايضا تور
وينسلاند يرى ذلك ويرى ان الاسرائيليين لا
يفعلون ما يكفي لماذا لا ترى الاداره
الامريكيه الحاليه ذلك ايضا
الاداره الامريكيه
ليست موحده حول هذا الموضوع وهي مقسمه
بشكل غير عادي حقيقه
الجهاز البيروقراطيه بيروته يدرك ان
الاسرائيليين لا يفعلون ما عليهم ان
يفعلوه لكن رئيس الولايات المتحده ليس
مستعدا لعمل ما هو اكثر لحملهم على عمل ما
ينبغي ان يفعلوه طيب هذه الظروف ما الذي
تغير فيها يعني نحن مقبلون على شهر رمضان
وهو شهر شهد العام الماضي والعام الذي قبل
دكتور غسان الخطيب شهد الكثير من القتل
والدماء التي وسيلت والاقتحامات للمسجد
الاقصى
هل نحن امام رمضان مختلف هذا العام وفق
معطيات ما خرج من شرم الشيخ
نعم وبغض النظر عن صدر من شرم الشيخ
الواقع على الارض وهذا هو الامر المهم
والحاسم الواقع على الارض يشير الى ان
العلاقه الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه مرشحه
لمزيد من تفاقم الصراع العنيف لانه الظروف
الداخليه في اسرائيل والعقليه السائده في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه وكذلك المستوطنين
الذين يعني تشجعهم تركيبه الحكومه الحاليه
متوقع ان تتزايد استفزازاتهم واعتداءاتهم
على الفلسطينيين وهذا سيؤدي بطبيعه الحال
الى ارتفاع وتيره المواجهه والتصدي
والمقاومه من جانب الشعب الفلسطيني وربما
انه المرحله القادمه في رمضان تتركز
كالعاده هذه المواجهات في القدس
وفي الاماكن الدينيه بشكل خاص لكن كل
المؤشرات تؤدي الى ان حاله الصراع العنيفه
التي ظهرت مؤخرا سوف تستمر لا بل وسوف
تزداد والذي يتحمل المسؤوليتها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والمستوطنين الاسرائيليين الى
اي مدى يمثل ذلك مشكله السيد
للاداره الحاليه لمنهالكه في جبهات عده
لعل اهمها جبهه الصين جبهه روسيا وحرب
اوكرانيا
ان لا يكون هنالك هدوء في الشرق الاوسط هل
هذا الامر مهم الى حد ان تتخذ الاداره
الامريكيه او تضغط بشكل اكبر على اسرائيل
اشك في ذلك اعتقد ان هناك اولويات اخرى في
العالم انتم ذكرتم بعضها بالتاكيد
اوكرانيا وبالتاكيد الصين وبالتاكيد كوريا
الشماليه حقيقه الامر ان الشرق الاوسط
لم يعد يستحوذ على الاهتمام كما كان في
الماضي وهذا هو جوهر الموضوع لهذا السبب
لا يوجد ما يؤثر على اسرائيل لان
الاسرائيليون يفهمون الامريكيين
بشكل ممتاز ويدركون ان الرئيس منهمك
بقضايا اخرى دكتور غسان الخطيب يعني الا
يوجد اي شيء يعود به الوفد الفلسطيني يعني
لا شك ان الفلسطينيين يريدون ايضا رمضان
هادئا هذا العام الا يوجد في مساله
الاستيطان وتجميد البناء والنظر في اعطاء
ترخيص والنظر في ت راخيص جديده لمده اربعه
اشهر الا يجدون في ذلك شيئا يقدمونه للشعب
الفلسطيني لحذف المجموعات المختلفه على
الهدوء لاسيمه في شهر رمضان
اولا لا يوجد تاثير للسلطه الفلسطينيه
ومنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه والفصائل
الفلسطينيه عموما على هؤلاء الشبان الذين
يعني يقومون بعمليات في مجال التصدي
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي وعمليات انتقاميه
وردود فعل
ومن ناحيه اخرى
من الصعب جدا توقع حدوث اي تباطؤ في
العمليه الاستيطانيه الاسرائيليه يعني
بالنظر الى الواقع الاسرائيلي الداخلي
وبالنظر الى الديناميكيات الداخليه في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لا يوجد اي احتمال في
تقديري بان يكون هناك تباطؤ او توقف في
عمليه التوسع الاستيطاني الشيء الوحيد
الذي يمكن
ان يعود به الوفد الفلسطيني وهذا احتمال
وليس مضمون هو ربما بعض يعني
المكاسب على المستوى الذي يتعلق باستعاده
بعض الحقوق الماليه المغتصبه من قبل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من اموال الضرائب
الفلسطينيه التي تسرقها في الحقيقه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه كشكل من اشكال العقاب
وشكل من اشكال الرشوه للمتطرفين
الاسرائيليين شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور غسان
الخطيب والساده العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت ضيفنا من رام الله ونشكر ضيفنا من
واشنطن
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونز
اذا مع هذه الاجتماعات فلت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه الرسميه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعتقل منفذ هجوم وقع في حوار اليوم وهو
جريح بحسب تعبيرها واضافت الاذاعه ان
المستوطن الذي استهدفه المهاجم واصيب
بجروح خطيره تمكن من اطلاق عيارين نحو
المنفذ فاصابه بجروح لم يتمكن معها من
الابتعاد كثيرا عن مكان الهجوم ما اتاح
للجيش القاء القبض عليه وتبقى لروايه
الاسرائيليه فان المهاجم استخدم بندقيه
بدائيه اطلق منها نحو 20 طلقه على سياره
المستوطنين فاصاب شخصين اصابه احدهما خطره
ودفع الجيش بتعزيزات كبيره واغلق جميع
المداخل الى مدينه نابلس كما اغلق الشارع
الرئيسي الذي يمر في بلده حواره
قال النطق باسم حركه حماس حازم قاسم انما
وصفه بالعمليه الفدائيه في حواره يرد فعل
طبيعي على جرائم الاحتلال بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني واخرها المجزره في جنين واضاف
حازم قاسم ان من حق الفلسطينيين اي يردوا
على جرائم الاحتلال بحق شعبهم وارضهم
ومقدساتهم بكل الوسائل واكد ان المقاومات
مستمره ومتصاعده وستزداد قوه وحضورا
وتجذرا ولا يمكن لكل الاجتماعات الامنيه
وقفها او الالتفاف عليها وبدورها باركه
الجهاد الاسلامي وما وصفته بالعمليه
البطوليه في نابلس واعتبرتها ردا طبيعيا
ومشروعا على جرائم الاحتلال التي كان
اخرها اليوم في ريف دمشق وقبل يومين في
جنين حسب بيان الجهاد الاسلامي
[موسيقى]
افتح لنا ملفا اخر قال المساعد السياسي
للرئيس الايراني محمد جمشيدي ان الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي تلقى من العائله السعوديه
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز رساله رحب فيها
بالاتفاق على استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين الشقيقين حسب
تعبيره واضاف جمشيدي ان الرساله تضمنت
دعوه رسميه للرئيس الايراني لزياره الرياض
وتعزيز التعاود الاقليمي والاقتصادي بين
البلدين واكد جمشيدي ان رئيس ايران رحب
بهذه الدعوه
وكان وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين الامير
عبد الله قد قال ان تعزيز العلاقات بين
الرياض والطيران سيكون لصالح البلدين وامن
واستقرار المنطقه
مو
اتفقنا مع السعوديه على ان تعود العلاقه
بيننا الى حالتها الطبيعيه وقد تبادلنا
الرسائل عبر السفاره السويسريه الراعيه
للمصالح السعوديه بطهران واخر رساله كانت
خلال الساعات الاربع والعشرين الماضيه
وكانت حول استعداد ايران لعقد اللقاء على
مستوى وزراء الخارجيه وقد اقترحنا ثلاثه
اماكن لهذا اللقاء وحسب التنسيقات الجاريه
سنتفق في اقرب فرصه على زمان ومكان اللقاء
والاجراءات العمليه لفتح السفاره
والقنصليه في البلدين
ومن طهران مراسل الجزيره عمر عواش انضموا
الينا الان اذا هنالك بحسب جمشيدي المتحدث
الرئاسي دعوه سعوديه للرئيس الايراني
لزياره الرياض واماكن ثلاثه مقترحه للقاء
وزيره خارجيه البلدين ماذا في تفاصيل هذه
التصريحات سواء من جمشيدي او من وزير
الخارجيه عبد الله يحيى
نعم زين هي زياره ان تمت ينظر اليها هنا
على انها ستكون زياره تاريخيه بعد انقطاع
العلاقات بين الدبلوماسيه بين طهران
والرياض دامه لنحو سبع سنوات وستكون اول
زياره لرئيس ايراني الى السعوديه بعد
زياره الرئيس الاسبق احمد محمود احمد نجاد
عام 2012 الى الرياض المساعد السياسي
لمكتب الرئيس الايراني قال ان هذه الدعوه
وجهت رسميا من العاهل السعودي وانها تاتي
في اطار تعزيز التعاون الاقليمي
والاقتصادي بين طهران والرياض بعد اتفاق
بجين واضاف ان الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم
رئيس رحب بهذه الدعوه وابدى استعداد طهران
لتعزيز التعاون يبدو ان هناك
التواصل مستمر منذ التوقيع على اتفاق بجين
في العار الشر من مارس يقول الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبدالله هيان ان هناك
تبادل للرسائل مع السعوديه لاجل اللقاء
مزمع عقده بين وزيره خارجيه البلدين
وتبادل الوفود لتفقد السفارات في البلدين
طهران تتحدث اليوم عن تفاؤل ازاءه ما
تسميه دبلوماسيه الجوار منذ التوقيع على
اتفاق بجين الاستئناف العلاقات مع طهران
لا يزال يجري علي شمخاني امين مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني جوله مكوكيه في طهران لا
تفصل بينها وبين الاتفاق مع طهران بعد
التوقيع على اتفاق بجينزارا
الامارات العربيه المتحده وجارل هناك
الحديث عن اتفاق توقيع اتفاق امني او
اقتصادي غير معلن وفق بعض المصادر
الايرانيه من شانه ان يعزز العلاقات
الاقتصاديه بين ابوظبي وطهران كذلك
الاتفاق الامني اليوم مع العراق لا يمكن
فصله حسب المراقبين الايرانيين
نتائج اتفاق بيجين والتطلع الاستئناف
العلاقات بين طهران والرياض لان طيران
تنظر الى هذا الاتفاق قال له انه يمكن ان
يفتح لها ابواب عديده في المنطقه والعالم
تتحدث اليوم عن انه يمكن حتى استئناف
العلاقه كذلك مع البحرين وهناك وفد بحرين
زارا طهران خلال الايام الماضيه وتفقد
السفاره التي اغلقت في اعقاب اغلاق الرياض
سفارتها في طهران عام
2016 كذلك على المستوى الاقليمي يتطلع
طهران الى تعزيز التعاون مع الرياض
والحديث هنا يجري عن الملف اليمني بعد
اتفاق بيزيل بين طيران والرياض زين زار
المبعوث الاممي لليمن طهران وناقش الملف
اليمني لذلك يتحدث الايرانيون عن انهم
يمكن ان يسهموا فيها الحل في الازمه
اليمنيه لكنه يؤكدون ان الحل الاساسي
ينبغي ان ينبع من اليمنيين نفسهم مثلم ا
يقول الايرانيون عمرها واش من طهران شكرا
لك براس الجزيره
ومنذ اعلان اتفق الرياضه على تطبيعي
علاقاتهما ومباشره الاجراءات لذلك تعاقبت
تصريحات من كلا الطرفين ومن اطراف دوليه
تعدد ايجابيات هذه الخطوه وانعكاساتها على
اكثر من صعيد وملف نستعرض ابرزها في هذا
التقرير
في العاشر من مارس اذار صدر بيان ثلاثي
سعودي ايراني صيني اعلن التواصل الظهران
والرياض الاتفاق على استئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه واعاده فتح سفرتيهما
وممثلياتهما خلال مده اقصاها شهرا اكد
البيان على اتفاق لعقد اجتماع لوزيري
الخارجيه في البلدين وترتيب تبادل السفراء
وتفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون الامني والاتفاقيه
العامه للتعاون في مجال الاقتصاد والتجاره
والاستثمار اعتبر وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
حسين امير عبداللهيان ان التطبيع العلاقات
يوفر امكانات كبيره للبلدين وللمنطقه
والعالم الاسلامي مشددا على محوريه سياسه
حسن الجوار لبلاده اما وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان فقال ان
الاتفاق لا يعني التوصل الى حل لجميع
الخلافات العليقه بين البلدين مؤكدا انه
قائم على اسس احترام سياده الدول وعدم
التدخل بشؤونها وتم التوصل اليه بعد
مفاوضات دامت عامين في بغداد ومسقط و
ممثليه ايران الدائمه في الامم المتحده
اعتبرت ان استئناف علقت طهران ورياض يمكن
ان يسرع التوصل لوقف الاطلاق النار باليمن
ويعجل باطلاق حوار يمني وتشكيل حكومه
وطنيه شامله هناك ونقلت صحيفه
ان ايران وافقت على وقف الشحنات الاسلحه
السريه الى الحوثيين في اليمن في اطار
اتفاق استئناف العلاقات مع الرياض اما
وزير الماليه السعودي محمد الجدعان فقال
لرويترز ان الاستثمره السعوديه في ايران
قد تحدث بشكل سريع جدا بعد الاتفاق وان
هناك فرصا كبيره ولا يتوقع اي معوقات
طالما ان بنود الاتفاق تحترم اخر مستجدات
ما بعد الاعلان تصريح وزير الخارجيه
الايراني بتبادل رسائل مع السعوديه عبر
السفاره السويسريه لعقد لقاء ثنائي وتطبيق
اتفاق بيجين ووجود الثلاثه اماكن مقترحه
لعقد اللقاء
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني ان التحقيقات القضائيه كشفت ضلوع
اسماء كبيره من الحكومه السابقه في قضيه
ما باتا يعرف وبسرقه القرن وهي سرقه اموال
من الحسابات المصرفيه الحكوميه تصل الى
مليارين ونصف مليار دولار واضاف السوداني
في مقابله الجزيره لبرنامج المقابله الذي
يقدمه الزميل على الظفيري ان اي محاسبه في
هذه القضيه من دون استرداد الاموال التي
نهبت سيكون بمثابه ضحك على الذقون وفق
تعبيره
سرقه القرن هذا اللي انتشرت وسمعت بها هذه
ضمانات ضريبيه سرقت بمقدار ثلاثه تريليون
700 مليار دينار
هذه فيها حمايه فيها غطاء رسمي رسمي حكومي
والان القضاء يتحدث مو انا القضاء يتحدث
عن وجود شبكه من كبار المسؤولين في
الحكومه السابقه
ساهموا بالتغطيه وتقديم التسهيلات
لشبكه من السراق استولت على هذه الاموال
هذه القضيه بالتحديد اذا لم تكن فيها
محاسبه
واسترداد للمال العام فاي حديث عن مكافحه
الفساد هذا عبث
وضحك على الذقون
واكد السوداني رفضه اي اعتداء على اي دوله
جاره انطلاقا من الاراضي العراقيه مشيرا
لان قوه الاطار التنسيقي خولته بايجاد
صيغه متفق عليها تؤطر وجود القوات
الامريكيه في العراق مستقبلا واكد
السوداني ان بلاده لم تعد بحاجه الى قوات
مقاتله
اعطوني تفويض بانه في حال تكليفك بالحكومه
انت وحكومتك مخول ان تؤدي هذا الدور
وتخرجون باتفاق واضح المعالم ايش نحتاج من
قوات التحالف الدولي مثلا نحتاج منه
التدريب نتفق هذا البرنامج التدريبي سنه
سنتين ثلاثه نحتاج من عندهم تبادل معلومات
اذا اتفقنا على هذه الرؤيه وصارت باتفاق
واضح ومعلن ينتهي بعد دور السلاح عد اي
جهه
ينتهي متى نصل مرحله نزع السلاح بشكل كامل
لانه احنا بدانا هذا واحد من واجبات
الحكومه اللي بديناها من خلال نقاشات في
داخل مجلس الامن الوطني بديله نخوض هذا
الحوار مع التحالف الدولي وهناك افكار سوف
تنضج الى ان تفضي الى اتفاق عندها لن يكون
هناك مبرر لوجود اي سلاح ثانوي غير سلاح
الدوله
ويضم لنا من بغداد مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
ابراهيم من اللافت ايضا في تصريحات رئيس
الحكومه العراقيه حديثه عنا الاتفاقات او
العلاقات الامريكيه الايرانيه والايرانيه
ببعض الدول الخليج وما يمكن ان ينعكس منها
على الداخل العراقي كيف فهمت هذه
التصريحات
زين رئيس الوزراء العراقي تحدث كثيرا عند
هذه النقطه وقال في بدايه حديثه انه لا
يمكن ان تنعكس وان بلاده لا تعتقد ان
الخلافات سواء بين امريكا وايران او بين
دول بعض دول الخليج وايران يمكن ان تنعكس
او من من الصحيح انت العكس على الاراضي
العراقيه
وتسبب من مشاكل هي الدوله العراقيه وفي
هذا الاطار هو تحدث وقال ان العراق رحب
بالاتفاق الذي ابرب بين السعوديه وايران
وقال انه سيساهم في احداث الاستقرار في
المنطقه
وايضا تحدث عن الدور الامريكي وتواجد
القوات الامريكيه
الامريكيه القتاليه في العراق وقال ان
العراق لم يعد بحاجه الى وجود مثل هذه
القوات القتاليه وفي هذا الاطار ايضا تحدث
وقال ان هناك رؤى وافكار يتم تبادلها مع
الطرف الامريكي في سبيل انض من اجل التوصل
الى اتفاق يحدد العلاقه المستقبليه
للتواجد القوات الامريكيه في العراق قوات
غير قتاليه هكذا قال قال ان العراق لم يعد
بحاجه الى قوات قتاليه نعم العراق بحاجه
الى التعاون مع الطرف الامريكي في مجال
التدريب تبادل المعلومات الاستخباريه
التمكين كما وصفها لكن العراق لا يحتاج
الى تواجد قوات قتاليه وقال ان الطرف
الامريكي او ما وصفهم بالاصدقاء في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هم يتفهمون
الطرح العراقي وقال ان هناك عملا يجري
الان من اجل انضاج هذه الافكار والرؤى
للتواصل بنهايه المطاف الى اتفاقيه بهذا
الخصوص تواجد القوات الامريكيه وتاطيرها
بشكل رسمي بما يلائمه وجهه النظر العراقيه
بالتاكيد سيكون له انعكاس كبير على
المنطقه لان عدد من دول المنطقه وخاصه
ايران ترى في تواجد قوات قتاليه امريكيه
داخل الاراضي العراقيه تهديدا لامنها
وتاطير وان يتحدث الطرف العراقي بان
العراق يسعى الى تاطير هذا التواجد من
خلال اتفاقيه لا تفضي الى تواجد قوات
قتاليه امريكيه بالتاكيد كما يرى رئيس
الوزراء العراقي انه سيساهم في مزيد من
الاستقرار الى عموم المنطقه وليد ابراهيم
مدير مكتب الجزيره في بغداد شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
نتحول الى حرب روسيا واوكرانيا وزار
الرئيس مدينه ماريوب الشرق اوكرانيا ونشر
فيديو لوصول بوتين على متن مروحيه الى
المدينه الساحليه التي سيطرت عليها موسكو
بعد حصار طويل الربيع الماضي زيارته التي
اعقبت زيارته للشبه جزيره القرم في الذكرى
التاسعه لضمها قبلت بردود فعل غاضبه من
اوكرانيا التي انتقد مساعد
للرئيسكي فيها ما سماه انعدام الشعور بوخز
الضمير لدى بوتين
يومان بعد اصدار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مذكره توقيف بحقه حرس الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين على الرد بطريقته الخاصه
انه حر طليق اكثر من اي وقت مضى بل هو
اكثر اطمئنانا رغم وجوده بعيدا عن موسكو
ها هو بنفسه يقود السياره في ماريوبل شرق
اوكرانيا التي وصلها فجاه تحت جنح الظلام
يجوب شوارع المدينه شبه المقفره ويتحدث
الى بعض الماره يزور اسره في منزلها
ويتحدث مع افرادها ثم يعرج على مسرح
موسيقي اعيد بنائه ويستمع الى تقارير عن
اعمال اعاده اعمار المدينه المنكوبه اصر
الكريملين على وصف جوله بوتين بالعفويه
لكن التحركات الرئيس في ماريوبل اثارت
تساؤلات عما اذا كانت زياره خاطفه تحتمل
كل تلك الرسائل والمعاني بالنسبه
للاوكراني فان اختيار بوتين المجيئه ليلا
يؤكد مخاوفه الامنيه كما ان الليل يخفي
مشاهد الدمار والخراب في المدينه الساحليه
الاستراتيجيه التي دمرها الجيش الروسي في
بدايات حربه على اوكرانيا
اخضاع ماريوبول فتح الطريق امام موسكو
وسلطات المواليه لها للتمدد اكثر للسيطره
على نحو 60 في المئه من مقاطعه دونسك
شرقيه اوكرانيا ومن ثم بسط السيطره بشكل
اوسع على اكثر من 90% من لوغانسك التي
تشكل مع دونيسك اقليم دومباس ثم جاءت
الاستفتاءات المثيره للجدل والتي بمقتضاها
ضمت موسكو
بمقاطعتيه الى اراضيها اضافه الى التي
تسيطر على ثلثيها وخيرسون التي يقع نحو
75% منها تحت سيطره الجيش الروسي
لم يعترف المجتمع الدولي بتلك الاستفتاءات
لكن موسكو تمضي قدما في ترتيباتها تماما
كما فعلت في شبه جزيره القرم التي زارها
بوتين في الذكرى التاسعه لالحاقها بروسيا
في مثل هذه الايام من عام 2014
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه السابق ومن وارسو
ينضم الينا
الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان الاوكراني
طبعا اوكرانيا انتقلت هذه الزياره بل هناك
من قال بوتين ليس لديه اي ضمير او اي وخز
ضمير السيد اوليكسيه كيف تنظرون الى زياره
بوتين الى كل من القرن وماريوبل
زياره القوتين الى الاراضي المحتله
الاوكرانيه لماريوتل والتي اصبحت رمزا
لحرب الاباده الروسيه ضد الشعب الاوكراني
وهذه الزياره يجب ان ينظر اليها في هذا
السياق والساق له علاقه انه قبل بضعه ايام
فقط تلقى
بوتين
امر اعتقال من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
والتي تجعل منه مجرمه حرب اليوم ومن خلال
هذه الزياره يحاول ان يظهر امامها شعبه
بانه
يتصدى لهذا الامر وهو يحظى بالثقه بنفس
لكن في ذات الوقت علينا ان نعلم انه
باقل من عام بوتين سيواجه انتخابات
رئاسيه في مارس 2024 اذا زيارته هذه الى
الاراضي المحتله هي بمثابه بدايه لحملته
الانتخابيه السيده في هل ترى كذلك واذا
كان يريد ان يدشن حمله الانتخابيه لماذا
يذهب ليلا الى مريوبا
[موسيقى]
اود ان اقول ان الامر هي زياره عباره عن
زياره الزياره عباره عن محاوله سياسيه
ونفسيه
واهمياتها تكمن في نقطتين اولا في نفس
الوقت تقريبا في العام
دخلت شبه جزيره القرم الى الاراضي الروسيه
ومن المهم ان هذه الزياره الى هذا المناطق
لها اهميتها من الناحيه النفسيه لان هناك
هجوما اوكرانيا متوقعا قريبا هو يريد ان
يثبت بان الامور على ما يرام الامور طيبه
وهي الرساله
للداخلي والى الغرب في الخارج ايضا سيد
فتور واذا كانت هذه هي الرساله بالفعل هل
تعتقد ان هذه الرساله وصلت ادت هذه
الزياره المبتغى منها بارسال رسائل تطمين
داخليه ورسائل تحدي خارجيه
اولا على من الناحيه
الداخليه نعم تم تلقي الرساله لان الناس
راوا بوتين في هذه المنطقه للمره الاولى
وهذا امر مهم من الناحيه النفسيه اما
بالنسبه
انقطع الصوت من المصدر
فهو اظهر في هذه الزياره بانه
ما زال على موقفه القديم الذي لن يغيره
ابدا
وهو عدم عدم الانسحاب من الاراضي الذي
استولت عليها روسيا في اوكرانيا اعود الى
ضيفنا
من وارسو الى اي مدى مثل هذه الزياره
تشكل
التصميم الاوكراني فيما يتعلق بمعركه
الربيع المتوقع
نحن لا خيار امامنا لان
هدفنا هو تحرير اراضينا كل اراضينا بما في
ذلك القرن بالطبع
هذا ليس مطلبا من اوكرانيا هذا مطلب حسب
القانون الدولي لان اوكرانيا لا تحارب من
اجل بقائها وسلامه اراضيها واستقلالها هي
تقاتل من اجل الامن
العالمي ومن اجل اعاده تثبيت الوضع
القانوني الدولي في اوروبا وفي العالم
منشكو رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
البرلمان الاوكراني شكرا لك ونشكر ضيفنا
من موسكو
انئب وزير الخارجيه الروسي السابق
قال فريق منسقوه واستجابه سوريا ان اكثر
من 500 خيمه موزعه على 68 مخيما شمال غربي
سوريا تضررت بشكل كلي جراء السيول كما
خسرت مئات العائلات النازحه بريف ادلب
الغربي ممتلكاتها وفي الاثناء تعمل فرق
الدفاع المدنيه على تصريف المياه وفتح
الطرقات المؤديه الى المخيمات بينما تحذر
الارصاد الجويه من سيول جديده مع استمرار
تساقط الامطار بغزاره في الساعات المقبله
همهم فاض كالسيل
تجلس ام عوض عاجزه وقد استبدت بها الحيره
تامين الدفء والطعام لاطفالها هو ما يشغل
تفكيرها
اوقات عصيبه عاشها الصغار بدايه الفيضان
دهنتهم السيول فجاه ولم يحملوا شيئا من
متاعهم
حبه سكر ما عندي حبه رز ما عندي
ما ظل عندي شي بالخيمه مو حطيت المونه
كلها راحت
انحسرت مياه الفيضان عن بعض الخيام
تحاول ام محمد اعاده تاهيل خيمتها
يعود السيل مجددا ويفشل محاولتها المتكرره
منذ الصباح
اكثر من 500 خيمه تضررت جراء الفيضانات
والسيول التي تشكلت عقب تساقط الامطار
ليلا حيث خسرت مئات العائلات النازحه
الماوى والملبسه والطعامه وبات افرادها
ليلتهم في العراء وجل ما يخشونه استمرار
معاناتهم مع استمرار تساقط الامطار
في ليله الفيضان مشاهد قاتمه لهون الكارثه
في المخيم يعود الرجال بعد اخراجهم للنساء
والاطفال
يتفقدون خيامهم على امل انتشال شيء من
امتعتهم لم تطله مياه السيف
اخرج خالي اليدين كالسيل افسد كل شيء يعني
الرزق الحلال مثل ما يقولوا طالعنا
السيارات بصعوبه طالعناها ظل عنا عفشه
البيت كله راح الخيم راحت او الحمد لله
انا انسان طلع بروحه الحمد لله كله بيتعوض
عملت فرق الدفاع المدني في الساعات الاولى
للفيضان على تحويل مجرى السيول وفتح
الطرقات المؤديه الى المخيمات المتضرره
ويحذر الدفاع المدني من تفاقم معاناه
النازحين مع توقعات الارصاد الجويه
باستمرار المنخفض في الايام القادمه
ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره ريفوت
[موسيقى]
نعود الى ازمه شبه جزيره الكوريه وعرض
رابع للقوه من كوريا الشماليه في اسبوع
تزامن مع اجراء واشنطن اكبر مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه بينهما منذ خمس سنوات كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان قالت ان كوريا الشماليه
اطلقت صاروخا باليستيا قصيره المدى صوب
البحر قباله الساحل الشرقي لشبه جزيره
الكوريه اليوم الاحد وقالت هيئه اركان
الجيش في كوريا الجنوبيه ان هذا الصاروخ
الذي اطلق من موقع don't تشانجري على
الساحل الغربي حلق لمسافه 800 كيلومتر
تقريبا قبل اي يصيب هدفا بينما ذكر طوكيو
ان الصاروخ حلق لارتفاع وصل الى خمسين
كيلو مترا وسقط في البحر شرق الجزيره
الكوريه وخارج المياه الاقليميه لليابان
ماذا حدث الاسبوع الماضي يوم الخميس اطلقت
اقوى صاروخ لها هو
سونج 17 البالستي العابر للقارات في ثاني
تجربه اطلاق صاروخي بالسي عابر للقارات
هذا العام ويوم الثلاثاء اطلقت كوريا
الشماليه الشماليه صاروخين بالسيين قصيره
للمدى سبقهما اطلاقه صاروا خيكروز من
غواصه يوم الاحد في ردود الفعل وزراء
خارجيه مجموعه السبع الكبرى دانه ما وصفه
اطلاق الصاروخين او الصاروخ معتبرين ان ما
وصفوه بالسلوك المتهور لكوريا الشماليه
يستدعي استجابه سريعه وموحده من المجتمع
الدولي بما فيها المزيد من الاجراءات
المهمه من قبل مجلس الامن الدولي
تقول في المقابل ان اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
ياتي ردا على مناورات الدرع الحريه
المشتركه بين واشنطن والسهوله التي بدات
الماضي وتعتبرها كوريا الشماليه تدريبات
على غزو باراضيها وتتواعد بانتظام برد
ساحق
هذه المناورات تجرى شمال العاصمه الكوريه
الجنوبيه الصهي على بعد 30 كم من المنطقه
المنزوعه السلاح التي تفصل الكريتين
وتشارك فيها مقاتلات شبح كوريه جنوبيه من
طراز اف خمسه وثلاثين ومقاتلات امريكيه من
طراز اف 16
وبعد ساعات من اطلاق كوريا الشماليه
صاروخها البالستي اليوم اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الكوريه الجنوبيه تنظيم مناورات
جويه مشتركه مع الولايات المتحده شاركت
فيها قاذفتنا امريكيه واحده على الاقل من
طراز b1 بي بعيده المدى طبعا هذه القاذفه
تتميز
بانها قاذفه الاستراتيجيه البعيده المدى
قادره على حمل رؤوس نوويه وايضا تتجاوز
سرعتها سرعه الصوت ومصممه لتنفيذ هجمات
نوويه او تقليديه والطائره
التي اعادت القوات الجويه الامريكيه نشره
في شبه الجزيره الكوريه تعتبر عماده سلاح
القاذفات الامريكيه وقد خضعت لعمليه تطوير
وتحديث متواصله
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من لندن
الباحث في دراسات
الامن بجامعه بجامعه كينج لندن وطوكيو
والسفير البريطاني السابق لدى كوريه
الشماليه سنه اهلا وسهلا بك يعني بالنظر
الى كل هذه التطورات يعني اذا وضعنا
الجبه الجزيره الكوريه على
ترمومتر
الصراعات والحروب هل نحن اقتربنا من
اندلاع حرب في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
اعتقد ان الوضع في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
مقلق جدا
وجمهوريه كوريا الشماليه
تقول انها على
وشكيع الانطلاق بحرب ولكن هذا ليس تقييمي
حيث ان الولايات المتحده قالت ان عمليه
الردعه تنجح واضح ان عمليه
الردع هذه لا تمنع كوريا الشماليه من
اطلاق الصواريخ ولكن اعتقد ان هناك مسار
طويل امامها بين اطلاق الصواريخ
تسبب بنزاع انا طبعا امل الا تحصل اي
اخطاء اذا تقحمنا في النزاع يعني هنالك
علامات لاندلاع النزاعات والحروب لا شك ان
العالم تعلم كثيرا في الحروب الماضيه هل
هنالك علامات لقرب اندلاع هذا النزاع الان
طبعا الوضع يزداد خطوره حيث ان كوريا
الشماليه
لا تلتزم بقرارات الامم المتحده
ولا
توقفوا برامجها لصواريخ البلاستيكيه ولا
تحد من قدراتها النوويه
انظمه جديده ان قدرات كوريا الشماليه قد
تطورت بشكل بارز وهذا يجعل من هذا الوضع
بالغ الخطوره ولكنني اعتقد لو استمرت
كوريا الشماليه في اطلاق سواريخ في اعاده
المسارات بدلا من ان تطلق الصواريخ على
مسار جوي قد يبدو كما لو انا في نزاع حين
ذاك هذا المخاطر تبقى تحت السيطره يمكن
ثلاثي النزاع واعتقد ان بعض الاشياء التي
يمكن ان تحصل مثل او غير اطلاق صواريخ قد
تكون اكثر خطوره مثل مثلا الطائرات
المسيره
او اي تحركات بالقرب من المنطقه المنزوعه
السلاح سبق وحدثت وقعت حوادث من قبل
كاستهداف سفينه كوريه جنوبيه وما شابه ذلك
لكن لم تؤدي الى اندلاع صراع في هذه
المنطقه هل هذا يعكس ان الطرفين يفهمان
جيدا معنى اندلاع حرب في هذه المنطقه
لاسيما ان حربا في كوريا الشماليه او في
شبه الجزيره الكوريه لن يكون بحال من
الاحوال منفصلا عن السياق سياق المواجهه
مع الصين سياق حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
اعتقد انكم محقون في
الاشاره الى اغراق السفينه كوريا الجنوبيه
وما حصل بعد ذلك في 2010 باعتبار ذلك
حادثه خطيره جدا ولكنها لم تؤدي الى
النزاع اوسع نطاق كذلك كان نشير الى
الحوادث التي حصلت في 2015 في المنطقه
المنزوعات السلاح حين كان بعض الجنود من
كوريا الجنوبيه قد تعرضوا لاصابات بسبب
انفجارات في
المناطق خاصه باستخراج المعادن ولكن اذا
لم تحصل هذه النزاعات نتيجه هذا الحوادث
ليس هناك ضمانه بانها فعلا سوف لن تؤدي
الى نزاع تتكررت في المستقبل
اذا ارادت كوريا الشماليه فعلا ان تتلافا
النزاع كما تدعي هي في الوقت نفسه تقول ان
قدراتها البالسيه ونوويه هي فقط للردع
ولكنها
تبعث بمؤشرات بانها مستعده لاستخدامها في
الوقت نفسه اعتبر ان الاداره الامريكيه
اذا انشات فعلا ان تتلافى النزاع كما تريد
كوريا الشماليه فربما قد لا يحصل النزاع
شكرا
الباحث في دراسات الامن بجامعتي
والسفير البريطاني السابق لدى كوريا
الشماليه
[موسيقى]
اكثر من ملياري دولار هي صفقه واحده
تذكرنا بحاله التشابك والتعقيد التي تسيطر
على هذا العالم الذي نعيش فيه وارتباط
الاقتصاد تقريبا بكل شيء في مناحه الحياه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]